Hi, I'm Sal Khan, founder of Khan Academy,
and with your support I'm excited to say:
Here's just a few of the things
that we've been able to accomplish together.
We now cover a wide range of academic subjects
including history, science, grammar, and much more.
Khan Academy is now available in more than 190 countries
and translated into 18 languages.
Millions of students and teachers around the world
are using Khan Academy videos,
interactive exercises and assignments.
Teachers use new Khan Academy tools
to assign practice exercises, identify gaps in learning,
and track student progress.
Nearly 1 million students took part
in our back to school challenge
developing new skills and growth mindsets
while celebrating their achievements.
"Are you ready to keep going and keep growing this year?"
Yeah!
Research found that students who use our Official SAT Practice
We've partnered with the Advanced Placement program
to provide free official practice resources
for over 20 AP courses.
We're really proud of the impact we've had so far,
but we're just getting started!
We have big plans for 2018 and beyond.
We're going to be working on lessons across subjects
for learners around the globe,
and as a nonprofit, we need support from people like yourself.
So please consider becoming a monthly donor.
Because together, I think we really can
deliver on the mission of
a free, world-class education for anyone, anywhere.